I don't know how much more time you have
but began something answer some
questions from yeah of course will Ryan
ever be a bucketeer if you don't know
what a bucketeer is it's a little name
that I gave my subscribers will you ever
be a bucketeer yeah i'm a bucketeer
right now people don't realize that from
John drink 196 what's your favorite
horror movie scream scream I think
scream is the perfect combination of
horror with right humor infused one
thing i don't like about a lot of horror
movies is they take themselves way too
seriously and they think they have to do
that in order for fear to be generated I
think screen has everything you wanted a
horror movie is is violent there's
twists there's fear there's you know
like it's meta like they poke fun at the
horror genre a lot I think it's great
and I also really like um Evil Dead 2
from labu selenium where Ryan completely
come up the closet uh no um okay I
alright man I told you I be honest with
you about [ __ ] there was a time in my
life you know the funny thing is I think
the number one most homophobic land is
youtube comment since so I know I'm
gonna get a lot of [ __ ] right now for
what I'm about to be honest about I was
also about to someone video recently
there was a period in my look it's that
same year on my dad died my
ex-girlfriend of like four to five years
cut me out of her life wasn't her fault
at all I completely understood why she
did it after that I was really like I
was really trying to be in like an
experimental face so I did my thing you
know craigslist guys to craigslist is
fully gay guys so i tried out some stuff
but in the end I realized it wasn't for
me I was like it was one of those things
were like people don't realize it i feel
i consider myself an artist i do a lot
of writing i do a lot of and I
experiments a lot even in these reaction
videos you know like let's do something
to generate a reaction out of a crowd
like it's so I experiment and so I went
through my experimental sexual phase and
in the end I realized two main things
one
not in the guy's been shoe the second
thing was I realized I really prefer
intimacy over sexuality I know I know I
make a lot of jokes where it looks like
I'm just a horndog pervert but and the
okay baby the cat president of me um but
but in reality are you okay baby I'm
sorry but in reality uh wait I'm sorry
I'm not gay and what else was there oh
yeah I prefer intimacy like I really
prefer the emotional connection as
opposed to it just being sexual i know a
lot of guys especially my age are more
about like now I just want to be single
and [ __ ] as many girls as possible I
realized I thought that might have been
me but that's not me at all like I
really love my relationship with my
girlfriend yeah i'll enter this room
went to breakfast on our one-year like i
love being whether more than being
single because being in love with
someone is witten okay being in love
with someone who's also in love with you
back is a million times more rewarding
than [ __ ] a bunch of hot girls you
know it's it's it's so much more and the
thing is when you're with a girl yeah
you're going to get temptations and
desires to want it like if you're
especially if you're a guy where you
might think about it like sex with
another girl or sexual thoughts sure but
at the same time when you're single
you're going to want love so you can't
have both at the same time unless you're
a swinger but you can't have both at the
same time and for me I really prefer
being loved over being it's being single
that sounds good that's a that's a great
answer Veronica's happy to hear that
yeah when she goes away I'll tell you
something else knows I'm just kidding me
see what a lot of people don't know
about me is I do a lot of personal
development I'll I listen to a lot of
audio I've read many books and because
you know when you go through a lot of
crap you have to do a lot of self
rewiring and self-motivation so I've had
to really develop my mind and feelings
over time
and I'm really good with like hearing
quotes and breaking them down and really
applying them into my life rather than
just being a guy who posts a cool quote
on facebook I like to actually apply
that [ __ ] the reason I'm bringing all
this up is because I really feel that if
someone not just thinks about something
long enough but really feels that
they're going to attain that or or get
it I've seen it in myself I've seen it
with a billion other people like Tyrone
magnets for example if we're gonna talk
about YouTube Tyrone is gonna get to a
million subscribers he grows incredibly
fast because that's what he thinks about
that's where it as hard as that he
really wants that goal that's why he's
growing faster than everyone else is
because that's his focus my focus is on
a million suns so I'm not getting as
many subs as him but at the same time
what I do want I am receiving you know
for me I'm all about retention meaning
how many of my subs are actually
watching the video there's the times
where you're like man I have over
200,000 followers and only 20,000 people
watches you know so I try to like make
content good enough where people or as
many of the people that are already
subscribed will continue to keep
watching the video so that's why I like
Tyrone and I can be similar reviews even
there was like a hundred thousand-plus
more ahead of me and subs we can be
similar in views because that's my focus
and instead of gathering a bunch more
subs all right Ryan writes each got a
new alright alright cool man it's just
fun this was fun this is great when you
want a QA then I'm going to interview
you let me interview you I'll jot down
my questions and [ __ ] but no I'm thanks
for sharing some personal stuff with me
too man like it was really cool for you
to like open up because it's so weird
for those like anyone who does comedy or
whatever they can pick up when someone
has pain but for those who don't do
comedy they just expect like they always
expect me to be like laughing and [ __ ]
or that's why when I give a reaction i'm
out like cracking up there like what the
hell's wrong with you who but or are you
serious or you'd a bad mood I've cried
many times I've probably at least four
to five times on my
channel like I'm talking not like a tier
it's like I'm bawling my eyes it's like
those moments I try to just keep certain
things real I'm very sarcastic and make
a lot of jokes but I like to be real and
I see it I see when you do videos
there's a very genuine side to you too
which is very admirable it makes sense
why when I first heard of your channel
you were at 2,000 subs now now where are
you at your like 18,000 yeah 18,000 yeah
man that's that's [ __ ] incredible my
first year I ended with 1,700 followers
I was in one year 1700 followers a
little over a thousand views so it's
pretty good my second year I just like I
ended with 70,000 that year but first
year it's incredible to hear where
you're at i can only imagine where
you'll be by your second here any man
yeah I should probably bounce but I do
want to say that this is your first time
seeing I'm Dante I know I always say
subscribe to this person's channel but
do yourself a favor check out his
channel if you like the videos subscribe
right away as I guarantee you that most
of you at least will really like his
content so if you haven't seen his
videos really check them out he's going
to be releasing a roustabout me
hopefully I gave him some real personal
information to use about me and I'm
going to be doing my little roast about
him after I see what he has to do but
hopefully dumb asses out there realize
this is all in good fun all of you I
know when this roast comes out people
aren't going to probably think I am the
meanest person yeah they're gonna be
like wow this is not the dowser I
subscribe my amusement I'm so hoping
that kind of attention finally diverts
from me to you but yeah that would be
nice actually cuz I just look like a bad
person but yeah thnkx for this this was
amazing and I guess it's a feature to
feature i guess to the future yes I
don't know what you're doing alright
cold man let's look I was lovely it was
lovely talking me to you thanks for
talking me Manning we'll keep in touch
hi all right